when i get asked that question you know
what's the best way to go about learning
a new language you know what do you do
in your first month right i often tell
people you could do a lot worse and just
grab a textbook and just flick through
it you know just read
like just quickly look at the grammar
points don't do any of the
don't start studying but just look
through see what the grammar points are
put it all on the map because once
you've got that um general awareness of
the the the kind of key
rocks grammatical the rocks of meaning
if you like the way meaning is expressed
in the language once you have an
awareness of that territory then that
you know that really does i think
it is very helpful and then you just put
flesh on the bone after that as you as
you carry on and um and
and actually consume content yeah
and that tends that sort of
repeats that pattern in other words
there's this sufi saying you can only
learn what you already know
and we've all had the experience that we
don't notice anything until all of a
sudden something is pointed out to us
and we notice it everywhere
and so to that extent i think some
initial overview of the grammar helps us
notice things that we might otherwise
not notice
uh
but
it's not enough so i i do think as i
getting back to my earlier point that
i would like to see uh audio books of
say portuguese grammar japanese grammar
whatever it might be with lots of
examples no quizzes no exercises i am
totally against any form of quiz or
exercise it's all about exposure
but when a certain concept is introduced
then there should be ten examples so we
get a concentrated dose of whatever you
know two forms of past tense whatever it
might be an explanation ten examples all
in the target language all with audio
and you can listen to that and it's
divided up into
uh you know chapters verbs nouns
whatever it might be adjectives
conjunctions and you can be listening to
this sort of explanation of the language
in the target language with lots of
examples so it's meaningful by that time
you're curious now you want to get
better at this language but you want it
in the target language it's meaningful
input it's meaningful to me i listen to
it it's just a thought i think that the
grammar right now is sort of focused on
trying to teach the grammar to people
who don't yet have much experience with
the language and expecting them then to
write this test and get it right
my view is until they've had enough
experience with the language they're not
going to get it right or they might get
it right and then get it wrong and then
get it right
and then it's nice for doing exercises
that they're going to be better that's
why we on the other hand someone who's
already at this b1
b2 level give them something that they
can treat as meaningful input
comprehensible input
and sort of start to refine their their
accuracy in the language
yeah and that's why we always get this
the the
examples of of students
who will say you know why is it that i i
always whenever i'm talking with my
tutor in a lesson or you know i never
have any problem and i can always get
the answers right in my textbook but
then when i'm out on my own
it's like i freeze up and and i and i
can't get anything meaningful out of my
mouth it's it's for that exact it's for
that exact reason um so you're talking
about i guess having exactly a huge
arsenal of examples so you you're
talking about having the the explanation
and then just pages of examples in in
the target language
10 is enough because let's say there's
50 points or 100 points that you want to
cover you're not going to cover every
possible situation in the language
but
50 or i bought a book once on russian
called 52 patterns
in the russian language it was great
that's how it was structured and what
would have been good there would have
been an audiobook to accompany it
so there's x number of patterns in the
language that if you have these patterns
you can speak the language
uh do you find an example
meaningful input for you because you
described it earlier as an input that's
meaningful for you and i'm curious about
that because i i've used um
programs like this in the past where
it's just you know huge numbers of
examples and sentences one after the
other and i just i find myself getting
bored very quickly precisely because i
don't find it meaningful and it's one of
those things where you know this is the
danger between pedagogy and just content
isn't it because
because
with content you you know you're going
to win in the end you know you'll get
there in the end right
and then with the pedagogy you've got a
leg up you can explain it more but then
yeah how do you stay motivated it's got
to find that balance in between and i
always
you know yeah
go ahead so i mean it's going to be a
part of your strategy it's not the main
thing the main thing is listening to
content that is inherently more
compelling
but i can listen to my persian
podcasts and there are patterns there
that you know i know what they mean
but i'm not sufficiently aware of them
so that when i speak with my persian
tutor i can use them correctly
and i have the feeling and certainly i i
try to focus in i'll i i have a book in
person i go through and see some of
these grammar points
i have a feeling that it helps me
notice these things so that eventually
when i speak i get them right more often
than i'm getting them right now
so yeah there's always the danger you
whatever you're doing you don't know if
it's doing any good you're flipping
through flashcards am i learning
something i don't know i'm reading a
dictionary am i learning something i
don't know we don't know
but i have the feeling that i would
listen to it
i would listen to it and certainly the
russian book helped me with my russian
patterns
um so it's just it's a minor point it's
not the main the main thing i'd i agree
with you is still stories
but uh let me ask you this steve what
have you what have you you know it's
been a couple of years since the since
the pandemic now and i could could i
assume if
could i assume that you've your language
earnings accelerated during the pandemic
or
did you find yourself doing that really
about the same
no i mean uh
i would say about the same i i put in my
hour hour and a half a day um
you know in the evenings or whatever i
listen while i'm washing the dishes i
wouldn't say it's accelerated though
what have you what have you learned in
the last two years about about language
learning is there anything that
surprised you or that has that you've
come to believe in the last couple of
years
yeah i think that i spend an awful lot
of time generating meaningful content
and so the if to the extent that we can
make that easier for people
uh we save ourselves a lot of time the
amount of time that i go to youtube and
i put you know podcast on history in
arabic and put it in arabic and look for
something and don't find anything useful
uh so i and no that might be because i'm
into arabic and persian but uh and then
i look at uh you know again sahra who
lives in iran she's put together this
sort of 26 part
stories on the history of iran each
story then followed by these certain
questions
uh phenomenal stuff if i had something
like that on the history of egypt on the
history of uh
the levant you know
to me content is the big thing making
content better granted i've been in sort
of languages where there is less content
available than say english spanish
whatever so content because
fundamentally it's still 80
compelling input
a certain amount of time spent with the
nuts and bolts of the language to help
you notice things and then when you have
the opportunity to use it
so i'm not a believer in talking your
way to fluency i i think you you build
up your potential in the language and
then when you get the opportunity you go
for it without worrying about the
mistakes you're going to make so none of
that has changed it's just that there's
this explosion of available content and
how do we best
access it how do we make it easier for
people to find it that was a big part of
what we did at link with our new 5.0 is
to try you know you've got now the
format that netflix uses or spotify uses
to make our library look a bit more like
that so people can find what they're
looking for content is is key yes that's
my big sort of takeaway from the past
two years yeah i i do it's interesting
you say the amount of time that you
spend looking for content because it's
often the same the same
i i find a similar thing happening and i
think this is this is an area where for
any you know budding entrepreneurs
listening uh
i think this is an area where there is
still a great deal of work to be done
is it aggregating
aggregating
compelling content
which is organized by
level in some meaningful way in
different languages
into into
into one place because i think there's
lots of it's easy to find stuff that's
that's that's that's graded by level
um and it's easy to find stuff that's
compelling it's extremely difficult to
find
to find stuff that is both of those
things and i guess i guess that's
because we are all such individuals and
we're all we're
you know we all have uh the
the kinds of information that we'd like
to surround ourselves with the kind of
types of content that we like to that we
like to um
to to to consume but i think something
something a lot along those lines that
matches the breadth of the whole
internet you know where we could do
where content could somehow be be bought
in from any source and filtered by
interest filtered by but by level i i
think that would be
uh yeah perhaps it's not possible
perhaps it's asking too much uh you know
i still find that 99 of things i ever
try and watch on netflix i turn off
within 20 seconds so maybe it's it's
it's wishful thinking but but that
is that single source of um
of of of compelling high quality
properly graded language content would
be certainly for me would be a real um a
real holy grail
yeah i think that uh a number of things
i agree with you and of course um lots
of different people are going to put out
all kinds of different content people's
tastes are different
and some way of being able to find what
suits your level taste whatever
there are ways of making stuff more
accessible like uh you know i think we
have the sort of translation
interspersed with the text
so you can turn that off or turn that on
so even though it might be difficult for
you even though you might find it you
know
very you know like quite a short look up
every word but if you've got the
translation interspersed it kind of
helps you along uh you can go sentence
by sentence which helps you a lot so all
of these things in fact i think that
link kind of helps you deal with more
difficult texts you know historically
people have said you can't deal with
content that has more than five percent
new words this is paul nation in new
zealand you know what is it
n plus one or whatever trying to limit
the amount of new words there so that
you're constantly able to infer the
meaning and you can read more
comfortably
and i think that's the big advantage of
being you know using a digital text and
or a system like link is you can deal
with stuff that has 10 15 new words um
the other thing is that um
what was i going to say yeah netflix
obviously is there's a lot of stuff
that's very silly there on netflix
but um some of these cartoon texts are
are tremendous and so it's it's really
up to the individual to find what he
wants and again we try at link to you
know if people like certain texts more
than other texts and this whole idea of
relating it to stuff that you looked at
before so if you're interested in
history you'll see more history stuff
suggested at you so that you can start
to get closer to people's interests
um we do try to have a thing in there
about you know you you sort of
self-assess yourself at a certain level
so theoretically things at that level
are being suggested to you um
maybe
so um you know obviously
someone who said i'm low or intermediate
they're more likely to find your content
let's say than a political podcast so
there are ways that different platforms
can help people find stuff
that's at their level and at their level
of difficulty however i still think at
link we're just scratching the surface
of what's available in all these
different languages and there's a lot of
change coming down the road as well
because google for example are now
moving into areas of kind of
instantaneous translation so it's so so
that you can actually listen to and you
see this on youtube with multilingual
subtitles and things like that whereby
somebody can um
you know be talking lie imagine we were
doing this on a live stream and then
google could will be live translating
that into you know
whatever other language and that's i
mean it's it's still it's still not
great but it's a hell of a lot better
than it was even a few years ago
and so i i think there are things coming
down the track in the next in the next
five ten years which
you know even if translation machine
translation never gets to a
place where it's good enough which i
think you know i'm skeptical over i
think that the
the the technology that it will enable
for creators around the world and people
to just start to make things i think is
super exciting and um yeah i'm very
i'm you know i'm kind of a technology
skeptic in general when it comes to
language learning but i've recently
become a little bit more excited so i'm
kind of i'm interested to see what the
next few years will hold
well i think for example if you want to
know how to say something your target
language you can write it all up in in
your native language and put it on
google translate you'll get a pretty
good idea
of how to say that in the target
language uh now unfortunately
text-to-speech is kind of hard to listen
to so i don't think you could be
regularly listening to that kind of
stuff but if you were trying to zoom in
on a certain kind of sort of terminology
you could write it all up in your native
language get it translated and you can
study that and acquire those
terms
also when it comes to
modern technology i use automatic
transcription a lot
i will go into podcasts in arabic and
in farsi
and i'll put them on happy scribe and i
get back like particularly in persian
it's so accurate the only thing missing
is is good punctuation but it's very
accurate there's the odd word that
doesn't make sense but 98 of it makes
sense so i don't have a transcript for
whether it be podcasts in arabic or in
farsi and i just go to happy trans
happyscribe and i have text and i import
the mp3 file in the link i import the
text in the link and i'm away and i'm
learning and it's it's events that are
happening every day so i'm quite
familiar with these events so
there again i'm using technology
yeah and when i think thinking back to
how things have changed i bought some
books on sort of media
persian or media arabic and so they'll
have and the book was written five years
ago and there you have you know
newspaper articles from 2015.
well i don't need newspaper articles
from 2015 i can listen to a podcast
yesterday and have it transcribed and
study it
so there's no need for that
one other thing that i find very
annoying is like i have these wonderful
textbooks
on egyptian arabic lots of content lots
of material
and i can get the audio from their
website but i can't get the digital text
so it's full of vocabulary that i don't
know
i can't import that into link
it just seems to me that
you know once i bought the book i should
be able to get the e-text
so that i can more easily look up words
a lot of publishers make the audio
available so that's good
but uh
another thing that bugs me is they make
they divide the audio up into 30 second
snippets which is a hell of a job then
if you want to listen to something right
i want to listen to five minutes at a
time not 30 seconds anyway that's all
personal peeves but
yeah we could go on for quite a while
here
yeah well you know let's see all right
we'll let we need to we need to have we
know what we need we need us we need
we need our version of the state of the
union
every year except this state of uh state
of language
language technology i mean just keep it
right
yeah i think though what you're doing is
very valuable
uh stories and you're providing a little
more of the sort of pedagogical support
which we don't really do at link
although we do have grammars for most of
the languages if people want to consult
them
uh but the main issue is to have stories
that are uh more comprehensible
because if people understand they have a
sense of achievement they're encouraged
to continue a lot of people they run
into something that's too difficult and
they're discouraged
the other thing of course that's very
important is
i haven't because i have your arabic
book and i can't really read it yet
but the audio has the audio is so
important
uh most textbooks are narrated by people
who are very bored
and if they're bored then the person
listening is bored
and so it's so important to make the
narration lively
uh and so that's again where authentic
material on youtube is more lively and
therefore inherently
more interesting for people to listen to
and i think where there's a greater
resonance then we learn better and if
it's boring
uh we don't learn
yeah and that's that is also one of the
great consequences i think of this
general shift in
in influence away from the big
publishers and towards individuals i
think it's a very very good change
because although it although it means
that the quality isn't necessarily
always there um what it does mean is
that you now get to engage with
passionate individuals who are
right creating content from the heart
and that is something you know and
there's a reason that the publishers are
partnering with the likes of of me and
uh
and uh and benny for example it's just
like
there's a kind of energy and drive and
and uh innovation right which yeah which
is symptomatic of the
of the the shift away from from from the
corporation to the individual creator
and that's uh i think that's a really
fantastic development and i'm looking
forward to
seeing more of that
so we should then do an annual review of
the state of language learning such as
the state of language learning that's it
yeah 22nd of march and every year yes
right so i i we've gone over quite a
while here
it's been great i could go and i know
you could go on for another hour
but maybe we should uh stop it here
and uh we'll commit to doing this again
uh
the first of spring next year
sounds good thanks so much it's been a
real pleasure okay thank you bye